you get me okay oh you used to that's
because I'm a trained child psychologist
come on we were together so big problems
in the office the new owners have
stripped us of any value everything that
we'd saved it's all gone let's get drunk
okay what do we know about these guys
legs on owned by Vincent Kruger
currently resides in Paris
Roger French no no no no no we're like
two rooms we're divorced
and you are holidaying together to see
if the flame still burns not mean so not
the flame is out snuff you know gone
let's go into you
Paris spending time with you having our
money stolen that'll do it
guess who's getting married look at her
neck that law is our pension you want to
do a diamond Richard he's not gonna give
us our money back that doesn't mean we
suddenly become the Pink Panther why
thrilled to be here dad help what we're
doing kidnap crashing a wedding stealing
a diamond I'm here to have some fun all
right we're in
I have you've gotta calm down
you got the gun I just decided it was
too dangerous but I made sandwiches
anyone hungry let's do this tell me
where my diamond is love is easy to fall
into Nike is much harder think of your
wedding as a driving test you take it
you pass and then you really start to
learn how to drive what did you learn to
drive like this
you're much more likeable these days
it's really handsome hello irritating